when i met jean i didn't like gene
but i also realized that this wasn't
about that it was about
i was better with him than without him
you met him through a friend a mutual
friend yes and
um i didn't
i i didn't like him why
tell me about your first meeting he was
um i came to my friend's apartment and
he said
stan meet gene
you know and he said gene stan writes
songs too
and gene said oh yeah play me one
i was like okay
and i played him one of my songs
and
i think that was surprising to him
because he thought lennon and mccartney
and gene were like the only three people
writing songs
and he played a song for me which
is long forgotten but my song wound up
on our first album
so um he has a big ego but it's also
it's kind of enjoyable i think he leans
into it yes he plays it for all it's
worth but jeans are
gene
ed hart is a good good person who is um
does more
charity work than he lets people know
and you know he's um
again he's my brother he
that's different than you know saying oh
somebody's your best friend he's not my
best friend we don't commiserate and we
don't spend a lot of time together
but um
he's always there he would always be
there for me you don't spend time you
don't socialize when you're not on the
road no but when you are on the road
though yeah we it's fun to to go out but
again we're we're different people and
we want different things um
when you when you were first starting
out and we're not first starting out
when kiss like blew up and you were
before you took off the makeup
um you said you had a i saw a glow and i
started talking about the ladies and
they all wanted to come backstage
but
the thing is that you would take off the
makeup
you were very secretive about who you
were were you not like um
did you ever find yourself in an
uncomfortable position going no no i'm
the guy
no but i did hear about
women who with guys who claim they were
me
you know
i said i hope they did me proud yes you
know yeah i would do that if i was
i was not single at the time but that
would be a great idea just to put a
little bit of like a smudge of makeup on
my makeup yeah oh did i not get it did i
not get it all off when you had the long
curly hair yeah i had longer i had hair
[Music]
you